good morning Hank it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters what's your
favorite band I don't know probably
rubber oh wait you mean like musical
band I've said it before and I'll say it
again the mountain goats are so jokes
favorite Vonnegut novel mother night
favorite Toni Morrison book Song of
Solomon
how does Steinbeck sin dubious battle
relate to the average teenagers life
well I guess it doesn't in any literal
way but I don't agree with the notion
that you have to be able to directly
identify with characters in order to
enjoy a book but what in dubious battle
is really about is group psychology
which is certainly important to
teenagers and it's also about the
relationship between the Machine and its
cogs which is something that you're just
figuring out when you're a teenager I
mean not to sound like a cranky old man
but I think we have to get past the idea
that art is something that's supposed to
be merely pleasurable Edward or Jacob
here's the thing about Edward Cullen by
the way I'm getting ready for thousands
of teen girls to throw rocks at me
Edward is a very beautiful but very
empty vessel into which we can stuff all
our hopes and aspirations and believe me
I understand that people who are
primarily ideas are a lot more
attractive than people who are primarily
people but I have to say that in my
experience being in love with a person
who's mostly an idea is not really a
sustainable situation all of which is to
say and nerdfighters please forgive me
Jacob what's the key to becoming a
popular video blogger on YouTube YouTube
just release this really interesting
feature that allows you to see the
demographics of your channel and one of
the things that we've learned when we
looked at the demographics is that
nerdfighters are extremely loyal I think
the reason for this is that nerd
fighting isn't something that you watch
out to do it's something that we all do
together the other thing that we've
learned is that out of our 296 videos
294 of them have been watched by more
women than men the two exceptions both
feature giraffe sex as the center screen
shot really men of YouTube you are
freaking me out please explain to me in
comments what it is that fascinates you
about giraffes who love giraffes so yeah
if you want to become marginally popular
on YouTube and help create a community
that you feel really strongly about
that's composed entirely of awesome then
building a truly collaborative community
is the way to go if you want boys to
watch you
I suppose the solution is giraffe sex
what would you like your last words to
be I've always felt that romantic last
words are almost without exception
really lame like the only exception I
can think of is WC Fields his last words
were gosh darn the whole frickin world
and everyone in it but you Carlotta
except he didn't say gosh darn and he
didn't say freakin but even those aren't
that Roman
when you consider the fact that Carlotta
wasn't his wife she was his mistress all
that said if I had the chance to say one
last thing I'd probably tell the Yeti I
love her how long have you and the Yeti
been married two years today by the way
Hank and Catherine thanks for the
sustainably farmed and beautiful flowers
have you ever been really jealous of
Hank no I mean sure he has eight of our
nine most viewed videos but I don't take
that personally I mean that's not a
reflection on me that just a reflection
on how great Hank is by the way who the
eff is Hank Hank is a tiny yellow
songbird said to represent the soul of
France Hank has an important but as yet
undetermined role in the omniscient airy
project if you could choose between
getting a million dollars and going back
in time and punching Hitler in the face
what would you choose hmm alright first
I would take the time machine I would go
back in time I would kidnap evil baby
Hitler and I would put him in the evil
baby orphanage in Tibet then I do the
same thing with evil baby Saul and evil
baby Idi Amin evil baby vlad the impaler
evil baby Lady Elizabeth báthory evil
baby Queen Randolph alone of the first
then once we had a really solid class at
the evil baby orphanage I would sell the
time machine and I'd get like thirty
million dollars and I'd be able to fund
the evil baby orphanage plus I'd be rich
but wait a second what if the guy sold
the time machine to went back in time to
the moment I created the time machine
before I got all the evil babies and he
killed me and stole the time machine I
mean then we have a Schrodinger's cat
situation I would be both alive and dead
and evil baby Hitler would with both in
19th century Austria and in 21st century
Tibet oh my god that's our premise Hank
I think the relationship between history
and the evil baby orphanage may have
finally been solved the reason we need
the evil baby orphanage is because the
second incarnation of baby Hitler is
still in the world and could still wreak
havoc even though the first incarnation
of evil baby Hitler also existed Great
Scott we've got it
nerdfighters still one question Tuesday
to go this week and remember I'm giving
away a copy of Paper Towns every single
day to a random comment or so please
leave your questions and comments Hank
you'll see me tomorrow